das ist das kleinste Hotelzimmer
Deutschlands und vielleicht sogar der
ganzen Welt wer kennt es nicht einmal so
schlafen wie als wäre man in diesem
Raumschiff von Star Trek oder sich
fühlen als wäre man direkt in Downtown
toky das soll wohl in dieser 2 m lang
und 1 m breiten Kapsel in Berlin gehen
die von innen aussieht wie ein Gamer
Kühlschrank oder montes Keller herzlich
willkommen in einem kleinsten
Hotelzimmer Deutschlands das Zimmer
besteht aus einer Tür die man direkt mit
diesem Knopf abschließen kann einem Safe
Bedienelementen für Licht und Lüftung
einem Bäcker und einer 5 cm dünnen
Matratze also wirklich aufs minimalste
runtergebrochen damit man sein Gepäck
nicht mit ins Bett nehmen muss gibt es
spinnte wo man alles verstauen kann für
Duschen und Toilette muss man auf eins
der gemeinschaftswärter zurückgreifen
das wird von allen Leuten benutzt aber
nicht gleichzeitig man kann das schon
abschließen und hat dann sein eigenes
kleines Bad die sind auch überraschen
clean wie ich mit meiner UV Lampe
herausfinden kann alles in allem nicht
ganz mein Geschmack aber dafür ein
bombenkonzept klar den ganzen Urlaub
will ich hier nicht verbringen aber wenn
man mal eine Nacht in den Schlafplatz
sucht wird man für 31 € für mich und hat
alles was man wäre das nicht vielleicht
auch was für dich denn